fate it protects fools little children
and ships named Enterprise
and we have a new one
but how does it compare to the vessels
that have come before her welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so to say the least
the new Enterprise the G is a little
controversial
I actually ran a poll on my channel on
the Community page and I said was it
right to rename the Titan the Enterprise
and it's after nearly 3 000 votes it's
still dead on 50 50. people either love
this idea or hate it now we're all
unanimous in our hope that we're going
to get Star Trek Legacy and love how
this actually set that show up
but in honoring the Enterprise are you
forgetting about the sacrifice of the
Titan
now Terry metallic has come out and sort
of talked about this a little bit any
sign of made a statement that don't
worry we're still gonna honor the Titan
we're going to see a Titan be perhaps
maybe a new Luna class in some future
iteration of Star Trek another Legacy
hint perhaps and I would absolutely
adore Star Trek Legacy to be showrun by
Terry metallis but the Enterprise G
decision
whether you like it or not is a strange
one now we actually should have known we
were going to get a new Enterprise at
the end of this series
the way they did the Enterprise F and
the way they dropped the Easter egg
really early on that she was being
decommissioned
really should have told us but I think
we were so wrapped up in the series or
at least I was that I just didn't twig
and I have done a previous video about
how I'm not a fan of this decision I
think it was the wrong way to go
but how does the Enterprise G compare
and this has actually started a little
bit of an argument on some of my comment
pages but also on Twitter Etc about does
the Enterprise G really fit in with the
lineage of the name Enterprise does she
deserve to be named the Enterprise well
in Canon a lot of the time the
Enterprise is called the flagship of
Starfleet
now this is a little bit confused and to
be honest
the Federation has always confused what
a flagship actually is the flagship is
supposed to be the vessel within your
Fleet that has the highest ranking
officer aboard about traditionally what
the flagship is it literally carries
your flag and well that's not really
correct for the Enterprise the
Enterprise just always had a captain on
board except for the odd occasion all
right when it was actually rear Admiral
Kirk or you know Admiral Picard at one
point
but generally speaking she's captained
by captains
now you can get Junior captains and
Senior captains but the ranking officer
aboard any Naval vessel traditionally
and within Starfleet is always actually
named the captain and Admiral is a
senior Captain a lieutenant commander or
a commander like Cisco or the defied is
a junior captain
generally speaking though the Enterprise
that we always got to see Picard Kirk
and so on were always captains so in
that respect she shouldn't really be a
flagship but she is considered one of
the most famous vessels within the fleet
and under Kirk under Picard etc etc one
of the most feared
is that true now for Captain seven of
nine and the g well the G is not a big
Starfleet vessel she actually sits
between the C and the D
the Enterprise C was 526 meters long the
Enterprise D was 642 meters long
the G 506 meters so she actually sits
virtually dead on between the Enterprise
C and D
now size isn't everything some people
say
but this vessel was clearly not
particularly well armed even though
actually from a phases point of view it
does sit really well with other vessels
the Enterprise f for example had 18 type
12 face Banks the G actually does have
18 Facebooks as well some strips some
turret but it only has two torpedo
launches and a crew of 500 where the F
had four torpedo launches and a much
bigger crew anything up to 1600.
the E post refit was massively far more
armed she actually had 16 phaser Banks
Which is less
put 10 torpedo launches one Quantum and
nine Photon torpedo launches they
massively upgraded her Firepower at
least on a torpedo point of view post
the refit thank you shinzon so the
Enterprise G may not be a capable
fighting vessel and it is the first time
we've seen a new Enterprise that is
smaller than the previous Enterprise The
Odyssey class Enterprise F was nearly
twice the length of the current
Enterprise G it came in at 1028 meters
she is a bohemoth of a vessel but the
antibiase G is an Explorer she's not a
warship and you could also argue that
has the Enterprise ever really been a
warship well that is another argument is
the Enterprise always the best the most
advanced vessel in the fleet well we
know that the Enterprise a at least was
a very capable warship she was built as
a warship initially to counter the
Klingon threat we know from the search
of Spock that when the Excelsior was
going to do some of its speed trials
that the captain said we're going to
break some of your speed records now
some of those speed records are when the
engines were messed with by aliens Etc
but the Enterprise was still the fastest
vessel in the fleet and the Constitution
class similar to The Excelsior class was
a designer vessel that lasted a very
very long time but at the point of the
Enterprise a we should say it's a design
that was 40 years old now obviously it
had been refit upgraded it was an
adaptable design similar to The
Excelsior
I would argue that the Enterprise a
actually doesn't quite fit in this
debate that was a vessel that was
re-christened and given to Kirk almost
as a gift
she continued to be the flagship of the
Federation as we saw mentioned in
Undiscovered Country and it was she was
still considered to be formidable the
Admirals actually said we don't think
anyone's going to mess around with the
Enterprise with Captain Kirk at the helm
but then every other iteration of the
Enterprise has always been
the most advanced vessel in the fleet at
that time The Sovereign class for
example was considered to be the most
advanced vessel ever built by the
Federation designed specifically to take
on the Borg so it does seem that the
Enterprise at least within Starfleet is
considered to be their version of a
flagship she's supposed to be the most
advanced the most capable the vessel
that is out there on the front line the
G reeling doesn't match up to that
criteria she is a small vessel
comparatively she's not particularly
well armed she is fast what 9.99 is a
maximum she was massively outmatched by
the shrike and I can't help but think a
large vessel say the Odyssey class
wouldn't have been so easily overwhelmed
now the new Enterprise has just had one
year of being refit and who knows what
new technologies they've got on board
but at the end of the day she's no
bigger a new larger vessel is still
going to be more capable more adaptable
and better armed so the G is always
going to sit middle of the pack
underwhelming in many many ways but with
a really big name and she's got big
shoes to fill
the problem is for me she doesn't have
the capability technologically weapon
wise anything to actually fill those
shoes she has a crew compliment that's a
third that of the Odyssey and things
like this when you're on Mission matter
so unfortunately I still have to
question this decision it seems like an
odd one now it's a decision that
obviously involves a plan but I don't
really want to see the Enterprises the
Plucky Underdog like the Titan a was I
want to see the Enterprise on the front
line and the Titan
it just doesn't match up the
Constitution 3 or the neo-constitution
class though it's a design that's grown
on me I didn't like it at first I
thought it was kind of ugly but as the
series went on I began to appreciate the
lines of this new vessel there's a lot
of very subtle parts of this design that
hark back to previous vessels so the
question the title of this video
does this neo-constitution class
Enterprise G deserve the name
I say not for me I question this
decision I don't think it was a good
decision I'd have loved to have seen a
new Enterprise I've said this before in
other videos I wanted to see a shot like
maybe the end of Undiscovered Country I
would have loved to have seen a final
shot maybe where a new class of
Enterprise is seen with the smaller
Plucky Titan and that maybe the
Enterprise flies away and a Titan begins
her journey I think that would have been
a really nice way of ending this series
and at the end of the day
the Legacy TV series
didn't need to be the Enterprise but
then it wouldn't have been the legacy of
the Next Generation would it and kind of
that's the point that's why it had to be
the Enterprise it's just
maybe a shame
but the end of the day this Plucky
little Underdog may do great things I'm
sure she will I just wish that if she
was a bit bigger she'd have been able to
maybe do greater things
but guys give the comments tell me what
you think this is a complicated story
and at the end of the day it's Terry
matalis's decision he's decided to go
with this and he has a plan and should
we just trust Terry get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you're
thinking if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
please also go over to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where you get to
see most of our videos first and for a
small contribution that helps the
channel out each month you get to see
them without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]